WTF, was ist das?
Alter, was ist das?
Ich will jetzt kein Windows Update machen.
WTF, warum muss ich jetzt ein Windows Update machen, Alter?
Warum?
Warum kommt jetzt ein Windows Update?
Almost ready, ja geil.
Das Fenster wird automatisch in 2 Minuten geschlossen.
Leute, ich bin vielleicht gleich wieder weg.
Windows ist der Meinung, ich muss updaten.
Ich weiß nicht, was gleich passiert.
Keine Ahnung.
Geil, Alter.
geil
Ich habe ich habe nichts gemacht
Hier und ich habe hier unten drauf gedrückt vorhin weil ich wissen wollte warum da ein blauer punkt ist
Und
Mal gucken was passiert wenn ich
Okay ist immer noch ein blauer punkt
Installing 20 prozent
Keine ahnung
Was da abgeht ich klausse das jetzt mal in der hoffnung ich werde nicht rausgeschmissen
20 prozent okay
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob überhaupt was gemacht wird, weil mein Windows updatet gerade.
Keine Ahnung.
Das ist ja zu geil, Alter.
Vor allem, warum 24H2? Hatte ich das die ganze Zeit nicht, oder wie?
Mach eigentlich immer Windows. Ach, keine Ahnung, Alter. Bei Windows blickst du nicht mehr durch.
Gibt es Arch-Updates? Ja, das ist gut.
Das müssen wir gleich checken.
Ach, by the way.
Also, Leute, ich glaube,
ich bin bald weg.
Weil es Windows-Updates
durch.
Ich hoffe, es gibt keine Probleme mit
VeraCrypt
mit 24H2.
Soll ich vielleicht mal besser googeln vorher,
bevor ich das installiere? Oder hat er das jetzt schon installiert?
VeraCrypt
24H2.
Sekunde.
Okay.
Stuckbooting.
Oh, shit.
Moment, vielleicht sollte ich mich mal dazu schlau...
Vielleicht sollte ich mich dazu mal schlau machen, bevor ich reboote mit der neuen Windows-Version.
Macht den Stream im Handy an.
Running in Legacy MBR-Mode.
Ne, das mache ich ja gar nicht.
Das mache ich ja gar nicht.
Guck mal, der hat Secure Boot enabled.
Hoffen wir mal, das funzt jetzt.
Ja.
Es scheint, dass der
guten Bug mit 11H2
in diesem Update nicht brummt.
Ich hoffe, sie kümmern sich bald...
Ach, geil.
Oh, shit.
Da habe ich ja gar keinen Bock drauf.
Sag mal, ist das...
Ach, das hat wieder hier Zeug.
Ja, okay, was mache ich jetzt, dass mein Rechner dann wieder funzt?
Ritz-Koll-Dankeschön für den Sub.
Issues.
Ja, okay.
Was muss ich denn überhaupt machen,
dass es danach wieder bootet?
Das wäre schlecht, wenn mein Rechner jetzt nicht mehr bootet, Leute.
Oh, Install Error.
Okay.
Leute, scheiß drauf, ich mache kein 24H2.
Install Error.
Okay, was ist das jetzt?
Sie halten eine für die...
Update.
Ich hab bestimmt schon 24 H2.
Nee, hab ich nicht.
Hab ich nicht.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Hier, hier.
Nee, nee.
Ich hab nachgeguckt.
Ich hab 23 H2.
Ich wusste auch gar nicht, dass ich das nicht habe.
Ja, das Linux-Desktop.
Ja, endlich.
Ähm.
Okay, Windows-Update-Problem.
Ja, du musst das System komplett neu installieren.
Was?
Wollt ihr mich verarschen?
Alter, wie scheiße kann was sein, Mann?
Wie scheiße kann was sein?
Aha, hier, guck mal da.
Der Deskmodder, der sagt uns jetzt, was ist.
Okay.
Okay, whatever.
Whatever.
Dann mache ich halt kein
24H2 Update.
Leck mich Windows, Mann.
Meine Güte.
Wie kacke kann das sein?
Ah, by the way, wir müssen jetzt mal gucken.
Ähm.
Wir machen jetzt mal Package-Updates
unserem 8. Linux.
So, jetzt kann ich mich,
nachdem der Windows-Update-Schock
erstmal überwunden ist, indem er nicht funktioniert,
kann ich mir den chat mal angucken ja was wird heute gemacht was wir heute machen ist es gibt
für go ganz viele so libraries zum erstellen von cli tools die parameter parsen und shell
completion machen und sowas und irgendwie habe ich da fünf verschiedene gefunden und ich bin
mir nicht sicher welche ich verwenden soll oder sollte das mit abstand wohl größte bekannteste
ist die Kombination aus
Cobra und Viper.
Aber vielleicht gibt es ja da...
Das habe ich mir aber angeguckt.
Das sah ultra bloated aus.
Und super kompliziert für ein bisschen
Command Line Parsen.
Deswegen mal gucken, was es da alles gibt.
Ich habe schon ein bisschen drüber geguckt.
Ich fand so auf den ersten Blick
Sarkong am besten aus.
So für Command Line Parser.
By the way, was ist da eigentlich
mit dem Clip?
Offiziell bestätigt nächstes Jahr wird das Jahr des Linux-Desktops.
Ja klar, da sind wir uns einig.
Was ist euer?
Was? Ein USB-Stick hat es verhindert, dass Battlefield 6 startet?
Die drehen ja immer weiter am Rad, oder?
Gab es für Windows 10 nicht...
Oh, wartet mal, Leute.
Ich muss mir kurz was zu trinken holen.
Sack.
Ups, gleich wieder da.
Gleich wieder am Start.
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
Da bin ich wieder.
Gab es bei Windows 10
nicht sogar jetzt irgendwie so eine LTS-Verlängerung
für alle?
War da nicht was? Ich habe irgendwas
bei Heise gelesen.
Dass es so ein Windows 10
Extended Support Ding für jeden
kostenlos gibt.
Oder liege ich falsch?
Was? Wir installieren Updates.
Achso, und wir müssen,
falls wir noch nicht installiert haben,
Das würden wir Go Land installieren, aber haben wir installiert.
Ich habe hier echt mittlerweile halbes Jetbrains Universum am Start.
IntelliJ, Sea Lion, Rust Rover, Go Land, PyCharm, Rider.
Gibt es sonst noch irgendwas, was ich noch brauchen könnte?
Also Webstorm hat mir nicht gefallen.
Das ist also ziemlich das einzige Jetbrains Ding, was ich nicht benutze, wo ich auch nicht genau weiß, warum man das benutzen sollte.
PHP Storm brauche ich nicht.
Ruby Mine brauche ich auch nicht.
Wollen wir hier Update.
Ach, nur für EU ist das.
Ach, nur weil man sich mit...
Ach ja, und was ich auch gelesen habe,
das mit Windows Update...
Wartet mal.
Und was ich auch gelesen habe,
das mit Windows Update
25H2.
Windows 25 H2.
Es verwirrt mich so sehr, dass ich hier die Lautstärke vom Mikrofon nicht einstellen kann,
sondern man muss, dafür muss man ja jetzt irgendwie auf Sound Settings gehen.
Logisch, ob, ob, wie, just, li.
Ja, ne, passt aber alles.
Ja, was ich gelesen habe mit Windows 25 H2, ist es jetzt so,
dass man wohl nur noch ganz schwierig lokale Windows-Accounts benutzen kann.
Und hier, 25 H2 Local Windows-Accounts.
Und das scheint wohl super aufwendig zu sein.
Was ich mich frage ist, was ist, wenn man schon ein installiertes Windows hat?
wo quasi Windows schon drauf ist.
Weißt du, wie ich meine?
Also man hat schon einen lokalen Account und upgradet dann.
Dann übernimmt das, okay,
RRRRRRREET.
Jetzt mal eine blöde Frage.
Ich stelle mir gerade vor, mein Vater oder so hätte Windows 11.
Der hat das ja nicht.
Der hat ja Linux Mint mittlerweile.
Was würde der machen, wenn sein Windows-Update nicht geht, weil irgendwelche random Fehler im Windows-Update-Programm angezeigt werden?
Der würde einfach ganz normal auf irgendeiner uralt Windows-Version bleiben und keine Updates bekommen und es gar nicht mitkriegen, oder?
Das ist auch irgendwie kacke.
Das wäre es jetzt noch
Aber das traue ich Microsoft auch irgendwann zu
Dass das lokale Account-Feature
Nochmal 30 Euro kostet
Windows 8 enjoyen
Windows 8 war auch so ein Ding
Windows 8, das war das doch mit dem
Ups
Windows 8 war doch das mit dem
fullscreen startmenü oder dann so ein full screen kachelding hat es das war auch so ein
ding man wisst ihr was ich mache leute ich habe die idee ich habe die idee wie ich meine windows
update probleme löse ganz einfach pepo burn money wir erschlagen wir erschlagen dass
Vielen Dank.
Und es ist jetzt nicht so, als wäre das
voll lahm und das andere
Was habe ich denn überhaupt aktuell für eine SSD?
Ich habe eine Samsung.
99 Pro habe ich.
Das heißt, die habe ich gerade schon.
Ja, dann mache ich einfach die gleiche wieder rein.
Nur mit 4 Terabyte.
So.
Spare ich auch nochmal 200 Euro.
naja, wenn das Original verpackt von Samsung ist,
die von Samsung verschickt wird, ich glaube nicht, dass man da gescampt wird.
Chat.
So, und dann werde ich einfach meine alte SSD
in einen anderen SSD-Slot packen.
Ich habe ja noch einen SSD-Slot frei.
Und werde Windows neu installieren.
Hier drauf.
und mir einfach die Sachen rüberziehen, die ich brauche und der Rest bleibt so.
Fertig. Der Rest kann dann da vergammeln.
Bis wann habe ich denn Zeit?
Windows 23 H2 Support End Date.
11. November.
Okay, habe ich noch einen Monat Zeit.
Zum Updaten.
Und bei der Gelegenheit kann ich auch gleich mal ausprobieren,
wie ich 25
H2 da drauf kriege mit einem lokalen
User-Account. Das ist doch ein guter Plan.
Ich habe genug SSDs. So ist es ja nicht.
Also guckt mal, ich habe hier noch
Ich habe alle meine
SSDs hier reingestöpselt,
die gerade nicht in Benutzung waren.
Und das meiste brauche ich. Ich habe sogar noch
eine 12 terabyte normale magnetplatte hast du windows pro ja habe ich wir sind doch professional
leute kauft ihr eine micron ich kaufe mir wieder die gleiche samsung ssd wie vorher wenn du nur
update ist dann bleibt der user lokal ich update nicht ich würde ja neu installieren mit 25 hat 2
doch mit 25 h 2 geht das auch nicht mehr da geht nur noch dass du irgendwie beim installieren trick
17 mit dem xml file machst oder du musst in der domäne join das geht auch aber ich mache mir
lokal keine windows domäne das geht nicht mehr das geht nicht mehr
das geht nicht mehr mit ob übrigens wisst ihr leute wofür ob steht ich weiß
es zufällig weil ich mich damals schon drüber kaputt klagen musste was bescheu
Name das ist. OOBE ist die Out of Box Experience. Ja. Du hast es vor zwei Wochen gemacht. Auch mit
25 H2. Angeblich geht das nicht mehr. Sag ich es wollen auch wieder am Start. Domain Join,
da brauche ich erstmal windows ad und so ein kack daheim das will mache ich mir bestimmt nicht
ja aber hast du auch 25 hat zwei gemacht das hat sich richtig nach china chinesen an
so hat es von einer schon mit 25 hat zwei gemacht und lokalem account also alles was
ich gelesen habe bisher das nicht mehr geht 25 hat zwei das einzige was noch
geht mit 25 hat zwei ist installieren mit irgend so einem komischen xml file
oder was in der richtung kahnung
probiert wir können das ja mal ausprobieren im stream bevor ich das 19 overlay dankeschön
für den sap wir können das ja vorher im stream ausprobieren ob das funktioniert
next cloud versus open cloud ich wusste was ist denn auch ein cloud jetzt schon wieder
ich habe keine ahnung ich habe auch ein cloud an die ausprobiert was ist ein open cloud jetzt
schon wieder open cloud eu die deutsche alternative zunächst laut aha habe ich nie gehört
Open Cloud.
Written in Go.
Aha.
Passt ja hier fast schon zum Stream.
Antivirus.
Was?
Mockerie.
Ja.
Open Cloud.
ganz ehrlich mir wäre opencloud ist mir auf den ersten blick schon deutlich sympathischer als
nextcloud weil nextcloud wisst ihr mag ich überhaupt nicht ich kann es ja aber nicht
sagen weil ich opencloud nicht ausprobiert habe aber wenn du tools brauchst die es nur
bei nextcloud gibt ja da hast ja keine andere wahl oder aber aber nextcloud ist eh paintschamp
Massive Paints Champ ist das
So, Updates haben wir installiert
Ich habe immer noch ziemlich volle Platte hier
Kann nicht am Windows Update liegen
Kennst du OnCloud?
Äh, ah ne, was?
OnCloud Infinite Scale
Ne, habe ich noch nie gehört
Open Cloud ist ein Fork von
Open Cloud. Open Cloud ist aber doch auch PHP.
Wie kann das dann Go sein?
Oder ist es ein Fork von diesem
Rewrited-Open-Cloud-Ding, was in Go
war? Weil das originale
Open Cloud ist PHP.
Aha.
Das habe ich nie ausprobiert.
Aber Go ist mir da schon mal deutlich sympathischer als PHP.
Okay, dann starten wir doch mal hier.
Das ist freier RAM, oder?
Das verwirrt mich nämlich gerade.
Äh, nicht freier RAM, belegter RAM.
Ja, ja.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, wenn das hier mal eine Disk wäre,
die geht aber ganz schön schnell runter.
Aber nee, nee, das ist belegter RAM.
Aber wir müssen den RAM jetzt mal ordentlich belegen.
Wir müssen ein paar IDEs starten,
damit wir ordentlich RAM-Verbrauch steigen.
Irgendwo muss es ja lohnen, dass man 64 GB RAM hat.
Nein, das ist was ganz was anderes
Das will ich überhaupt nicht
Das brauch ich überhaupt nicht
Oder sagen wir mal so
Vielleicht nicht verkehrt das als Grund
Ne, ne, ne
Wir machen ein neues
Wir machen ein neues Go-Project
Wie macht man das hier drüber eigentlich?
New?
Boah, es leckt
Ist die Musik abgekackt gerade?
Kann das sein?
Warum ist die Musik abgekankt?
Ah.
An error occurred.
Please try again later.
Das ist bestimmt
YouTube Werbungsstelz gewesen, oder?
Hier waren wir irgendwo.
So, irgendwo da.
so also jetzt war new project hat das keine ahnung der cli champ go 1 253 das
ist die neueste version glaubt er label rendering support was ist das überhaupt
ich lasse es einfach mal an nicht dass mich das große jungen sample code
brauchen wir nicht. Was wird heute gebaut? Wir gucken uns heute mal an was es für
CLI Frameworks für Go gibt, wo man Kommandozeilen Anwendung mit erstellen
kann. Ich habe da schon mal ein bisschen
rumgeguckt, hab gleich mal irgendwie acht Stück oder so gefunden.
Das verbreitetste ist wohl Cobra und Viper zusammen ist wohl das
verbreitet dafür go und das habe ich mir aber angeguckt und muss sagen es ist bloatet es
fuck gewesen auf waren es auf den ersten blick aus die haben ein eigenes tool ums die sachen
zu generieren habe ich auch noch jetzt reden sie aber komplett ab was ist ein ziel framework er
hat eine library mit der du einfach aus juli anwendungen programmieren kannst das zum beispiel
sowas hier machen kannst hier blub minus minus 0 gleich 1 so und das wird dann gepaar und dann
ist das intervall gleich fünf minuten das wird dann gepasst und wird in die richtigen variablen
geschrieben dann kannst du das von kommandozeilen argumenten einlesen oder du kannst das aus
environment variablen also schwebt mir das zumindest vor kennst du bubbletee das kenne
das ist für so kommandozeilen gui dinger da kannst du kannst du kästchen malen und progress
barth mal und spinner malen und so was ja da habe ich aber nichts groß mitgemacht ich kenne
das aber das ist so quasi spektakonsole für go er kommt sample code darfst du adden
Zack, this window.
Dann müssen wir die Schrift ein bisschen größer machen, weil das ist doch etwas klein.
NetChat, busy klar, wie man auf Hessisch sagen würde, busy klar ist das.
Ganz schön klar.
Pond.
Warum? Das ist so ein Ding, was mich an den Settings hier immer fertig macht.
Wenn du nach Font suchst, du findest einfach immer nicht in dieser Quick-Suche diesen Eintrag hier.
So, 16. Bam.
Oder soll ich noch größer machen, Chat? Oder reicht das?
FMT oder hier Log, Print.
Hello World.
Das ist ja nicht so weh.
Reicht. Ich kann noch eins größer machen.
Eins können wir noch größer machen.
So, machen wir hier noch einen Terminal auf.
Das hier neben kann man ein bisschen kleiner machen.
Terminal auf. Wir müssen nach
Go, Land,
Project,
CLI, Champ.
Go, Build.
Go, Run.
Okay.
Und
das C, Go
enabled oder irgendwie so,
dass man das able sie go dass das auch schön self content alles ist sie go enabled muss man machen
kann 0 ok wunderbar das funst da gucken wir uns jetzt erstmal auf github so um ich mache
eins mache ich noch größer für die mobile viewers was außer args passen
brauchst du noch ein weihmann fach hier ab automatische help generierung shell
completion für die für die argumente dass man dann sagen kann
was man sagen kann hier keine ahnung blubb completion cdh oder sowas
bisschen wie bei cube ctl oder so oder solchen geschichten es wäre schon nice
aber im kern ist es wahrscheinlich so kommandozeilen argument argumente parser
mit ein bisschen extra Wurscht dabei.
Oh, mal 18.
So, jetzt ist aber
Pipo fett genug, oder?
Ich, ich,
wisst ihr, ich bin ganz merkwürdig.
Eigentlich ist so natürlich
die bessere Ansicht, aber irgendwie
komme ich mir so nackig vor, wenn ich nicht
diesen Explorer hier auf der Seite offen habe.
Geht das noch jemand so?
Ich benutze dieses Ding so gut wie nie.
Ich navigiere teilweise Files über Klicken hier, über Suchen.
Aber das Ding benutze ich selten.
Aber ich lasse den immer auf.
Komisch, ne?
Ich sehe schon, bei euch ist es auch so.
Ja, merkwürdig.
Merkwürdige Sache.
Ich komme mir da irgendwie so nackig vor, wenn der nicht auf ist.
Man muss dann immer so weit nach links schauen.
Das kann tatsächlich sein.
Das kann tatsächlich sein, dass es daran liegt, dass einem das deswegen so ungewohnt vorkommt oder so merkwürdig, weil man dann weiter nach links gucken muss.
Das stimmt, das wird es wahrscheinlich sogar sein.
Ja, und hier guckst du gerade auf den Monitor.
Ja, das ist es wahrscheinlich.
Okay, also GitHub.
Da gibt es doch immer so schöne Listen hier.
Awesome Go oder so.
Da gucken wir jetzt mal nach, was es hier alles gibt.
Also was ich schon gefunden habe an CLI Frameworks.
So, also was ich schon, was ich kenne ist Cobra, das da, gepaart mit Viper.
So, das ist so auch das mit Abstand bekannteste wohl für Go, hat 42.000 Sterne, fast so viel wie der Fiat Champ.
und dann gibt es noch
Viper
auf GitHub
und das ist für
Config Files
achso vielleicht sollte ich erstmal aufschreiben was ich eigentlich
haben will
ja Kong, Kong habe ich mir auch angeguckt
Kong sah von allen Sachen die ich bisher gesehen habe irgendwie am
besten aus
also was ich
gerne hätte ist also sowas wie
ich hätte gerne so
fangen wir mal an hier
command line
parser
das
ohne funktioniert ja logischerweise
nicht
help
generierung
dass der halt automatischen help commands
draus baut
dann kleine
binary size, das sollte jetzt für
so command line parser keinen allzu großen Unterschied
machen, aber
weiß man ja nie
also wenn ich die Auswahl hab zwischen
zwischen der Library die irgendwie 30 MB-Binaries produziert und die anderen nur 10, dann nehme ich
lieber die 10 produziert. Dann env-variablen-support optional json-file-config-support. Das wird dann
in der quasi laufen also wie das sich der reihe nach überschreibt ist dann quasi sie
größer größe config file so also wenn du was als die leih argument angegeben hast gilt das immer
überschreibt 11 und config hast was als entlang gegeben überschreibt sie konflikt so in der
reihenfolge das aber optional ich brauche nicht unbedingt chase config file support aber wenn es
das kann warum nicht ja dann hätte ich gerne noch so was wie hier in prefix dass man dann
nicht jedes mal sagen muss hier blubb anders oder sowas sondern dass der automatisch das für
einen macht also ich will hauptsächlich command line argumente und environment war er und diese
command line argumente will ich entweder per command line argumente setzen können oder halt
per environment-Variablen, weil
ich relativ viele Sachen mache,
die dann am Endeffekt in Kubernetes laufen.
Und da
sind environment-Variablen
ganz nice für.
Ne, autocomplete
will ich nicht. Autocomplete soll der auch haben.
Shell-Completion?
Also wäre nice.
Ja.
Vielleicht gibt es ja für Go auch irgendein Package,
mit dem man
easy Shell-Completion generieren kann, unabhängig
von dem eingesetzten hier Command Line Parser.
Das wäre auch nicht verkehrt.
Dann muss es nicht unbedingt integriert sein.
So.
Und was ich auch gerne hätte, ist,
dass das zur Not auch ohne, ohne, ähm,
ohne Subcommands und so funzt.
Also, also ich will, ich will sagen können,
Punkt Slash Blub und es soll funktionieren.
Ich will nicht sagen müssen, Punkt Slash Blub Start oder so.
Also es sollte
Oder man sollte zumindest
Irgendeinen Default Command angeben können
Was der ausführt
Wenn man
Ohne extra Command aufruft
So
Das ist jetzt das erste beste was mir da so
Einfällt
So Cobra Viper kenne ich
Das ist beides saumäßig verbreitet
Cobra ist für
command line argumente und wiper ist für config sachen aus environment variablen
und sowas aber wir gucken mal was es sonst noch so gibt
gibt es sowas wie CLI hier guck mal hier command line advanced ui standard CLI
boah ey da gibt es 30.000 sachen okay was haben wir denn hier also alles unter
100 GitHub-Stern nehme ich nicht.
Okay, aber das hat bestimmt keine Completion, ne?
Oh!
Was ist das?
Aha!
Aber das ist, das ist so ein, so ein, so ein...
Ein altes Package, kaum zu...
Wir gucken erstmal ein bisschen nach GitHub-Sternen.
Wir gucken jetzt mal ein bisschen nach GitHub-Sternen.
Hier, Cobra.
Das kenne ich.
Okay, wir müssen mal kurz...
Wir machen jetzt erstmal die ganzen Fensterchen hier auf.
Und dann gucken wir mal nach.
Und gucken mal, dass wir die nehmen, die...
Sagen wir mal 1000 Sterne plus vielleicht haben.
Oder halt recht neu sind noch.
Also.
Das brauchen wir...
Brauchen wir nicht.
command argument completion generator
was ist das aha
command argument completion generator für cobra ja moment das geht dann aber
aber nur zur quasi zur Compile Zeit oder wie ist das?
Was soll denn das sein?
Das ist mir schon wieder zu hoch. Ja krasse Documentation.
What the fuck?
Das ist mir zu high IQ.
Das können wir mal speichern.
Da hat es Sonderzeichen drin.
Das will ich nicht.
Cobra, das hatten wir schon.
der complete ritebash completions in go plus go ok
tech based environment configuration sowas brauche ich flag war
aschikop sie haben selbst damals okay
Wo ist denn Kong?
Kong kenne ich nämlich auch.
Wusste gar nicht, dass das da nicht drinsteht.
Dann taugt die Liste nichts, oder?
Das habe ich auch schon mal irgendwo gelesen.
Ach, hier steht Kong drin.
Configuration.
Aha.
Dann bringt mir die Liste natürlich was.
Also das habe ich letztens schon gefunden, als ich danach mal gesucht habe.
Ich finde, das sah auf den ersten Blick mit am besten aus.
Kong hat auch Auto-Completion. Echt? Nice. Dann probieren wir das als erstes aus.
Beste.
Oder nee, wir probieren als erstes mal das mit den 40.000 Sternen aus.
und dann gucken wir mal, ob sich das lohnt.
Also hier habe ich mir das schon angeguckt, wie man so Command-Line-Argumente und so definiert
und ich finde, das sah ganz okay aus.
Das einzige, was ein bisschen pepeger war, war hier dieses komische Annotation-Gedöns hinten dran.
Aber da muss man sich dran gewöhnen wahrscheinlich.
Das machen wir alles mal dicht hier.
Ja, vor 10 Jahren aktualisiert, ja, keck, wait.
Codra
Completion
Ah, das hat auch
ordentlich was
So
Da probieren wir das doch mal aus hier
Also wir wollen eine simple
Command Line Anwendung machen, die
Also aufrufen will ich das Ganze
mit CLI Champ
Und dann machen wir sowas wie hier irgendwie
Data Dear oder sowas
Gleich Kek W
oder hier slash slash keg w
oder was auch immer
und dann machen wir hier
äh, Intervall gleich
10, so, das will ich
aufrufen können und das soll ordentlich gepasst
werden
plus vielleicht
noch mehr, was mir dann einfällt
ach ja, und das ganze will ich
setzen können aus
Command, äh, hier
per Environment Variable
oder Passierlei-Argument.
Da gucken wir doch mal,
wie das mit Cobra zusammen
funktioniert.
Okay, gibt es schon mal keine Hilfe für?
Gibt es kein Example?
Auf die Fs.
Ist bestimmt abgelaufen heute.
Wie konnte man sich nochmal das Zertifikat anzeigen lassen?
Wo ist der Knopf für das hier?
General?
Hä?
Wo ist denn hier das?
Bin ich jetzt total hängen geblieben?
Wo ist denn das Zertifikat?
Kann das sein, dass das kein Zertifikat hat?
Firefox-Logik.
She baited.
Firefox macht komische Dinger.
bild modernes wir schieben das mal kurz hier rüber
max informiere mich derzeit viel mit den uns als us und überlege zu wechseln da kann man
ja das ist doof ja was ist deine meinung linux gaming siehst den nächsten jahren vielleicht
das ist mittlerweile echt ein übel also du kannst sehr viele spiele mittlerweile unter
Spielen sobald aber halt Sachen spielen also sobald du dir sicher sein willst dass du dir ein neues Spiel wenn es rauskommt kaufen kannst und dann geht's auch und du willst Sachen mit Anti-Cheat spielen ist halt schwierig die meisten Spiele funktionieren mittlerweile aber ganz brauchbar.
Ja, also ich sag mal, wenn man wirklich hauptsächlich spielen will mit seinem Computer und das halt auch aktuelle Online-Games, die ja fast alle, sei es jetzt Valorant, Rainbow Six oder was immer, Anti-Cheat haben, da gehen viele nicht.
Es gibt aber auch welche, die gehen.
Wie sieht es mittlerweile mit CSGO aus?
Es geht auch, oder?
Ich habe CSGO noch nie unter Linux ausprobiert.
Äh, nicht CSGO. CS2.
Nicht CSGO.
Ich glaube, das geht.
So, also wie funzt das hier jetzt?
AI-Ready. Kann mir mal irgendjemand erklären, wie ein CLI-Framework AI-Ready sein kann?
Das ist doch einfach nur, weil es gut klingt, oder? Das hat doch absolut nichts mit AI zu tun.
Buzzword, ja.
ich hätte gerne irgendwie mal so ein getting started ding jetzt startet ok
also wir installieren cobra latest install the cobra stil generator what the fuck das habe ich
letzten schon mal irgendwo gelesen ich brauche doch kein cli generator um das
juli ab was ist denn das dass deswegen wollte ich cobra nicht verwenden weil
das auf den ersten blick schon bloat es fuck ausgesehen hat ich brauche einen
generator damit ich den cli command generaten kann ich will ich will sowas
hier machen app commands blub also ich brauche doch keinen extra generator für
probiere ich nicht aus sehe ich nicht ein das war ich nicht das war ich nicht das kommt mir
nicht in die tüte die night ich würde es aber interessieren okay weil du es bist chat chat
weil ihr seid okay weil ihr seid machen wir das jetzt aber ich will es nicht verwenden
haben wir schon cobra library getten okay wir getten die cobra library das kann ich
auch über die idee machen aber es egal initialize your project das muss ich doch das kann ich doch
alles über egal mugi war danke für den sub jetzt wird das mal das halbe internet runtergeladen
es ist ja kein ist ja kein modul so und jetzt cobra cli
Den habe ich doch gar nicht installiert.
Cobra CLI.
Aber das habe ich gerade installiert
oder was? Cobra CLI. Ach, hier.
Okay.
Cobra CLI, äh, das gibt es nicht.
Nice.
Ich wette mit dir, ich habe die Sache nicht
im Path drin.
Wo installiert denn Go Install irgendwas?
Nach Go?
Bin?
Okay.
er habe ich da auch drin da machen wir das doch wo war das hier go bin cobras jli in
Okay und du?
Okay, der hat irgendwas...
Was macht das im Hintergrund? Ich will einfach nur eine CRI-Anwendung basteln.
Was will das von mir?
was will das ding von mir
warum habe ich da jetzt 3000 sachen auf einmal
ok so sieht das so sieht die app dann aus naja
ok wir machen wir machen trotzdem mal die idee
ran usc
ok jetzt kriegen wir hier den text
Test new
surf command.
Ah, hier. Cobra CLI add.
Das ist ganz schön... Also das ist wirklich
eklig bloated.
Aha, so wird das jetzt hinzugefügt.
Ich weiß
nicht leute irgendwie sagt mir das überhaupt nicht zu mit so einem generator und sowas ich
meine warum gibt es überhaupt einen generator ich meine das zeug kann man doch ohne probleme
von hand erstellen das wäre finde ich auch viel klarer ehrlich gesagt das gefällt mir das gefällt
Wenn ich...
Dabei an sich ist das gar nicht so schlimm.
Ich meine...
Löschen wir diesen ganzen Krempel mal kurz hier.
Dass man ein bisschen...
Ein bisschen besser sieht, was Sache ist.
Dann hält sich doch eigentlich ein Grenzen.
Warum braucht man dafür jetzt einen Generator?
Ich meine...
Es ist jetzt nicht so, als wäre das hochkomplex.
warum machst du es nicht über sys args weil ich nehme command line passung automatische
help generierung haben will environment variablen support eventuell sachen aus
dem jason config file einlesen will shell completion generieren lassen will ja das
war zum größten also generator braucht kein mensch aber dadurch dadurch finde
ich ist der sehr programm flow auch irgendwie schlecht zu checken also cmd
execute machte er für das hier aus gut command execute
Das finde ich super kompliziert.
Also das weiß ich nicht.
Init?
Was?
Wie ist das in Go?
Kleingeschriebene Sachen sind privat.
Großgeschriebene Sachen sind public.
So war das doch.
Fast.
So geht das im Mode.
Genau.
also
das gefällt mir und woher weiß er jetzt dass es dieses command überhaupt gibt aber weil
man cobra command aufgerufen hat
aber woher weiß der dass er das initial einmal ausführen muss
weil ein Cobra Command
aufgerufen wurde wahrscheinlich
ja okay
naja
geht schon irgendwo
klar, so richtig
schön und gefallen tut es mir
ehrlich gesagt nicht
aber ich glaube damit kommt man
klar, na gut, dann gucken wir uns das trotzdem mal
kurz an, wir machen jetzt
mal was ganz simples also wir machen jetzt eine anwendung ich will ja gar kein sub command haben
root command reicht mir voll und ganz aus ich möchte ich möchte es mal wieder ich lasse es
machen das so was ich machen will also was ist denn wenn ich das jetzt her aufrufe go go run
sage ich minus help ok das checkt ja schon mal das ist doch eigentlich ganz nett aus die die
automatische help generierung die japan also help geht auch ja aber was ist wenn
ich jetzt will dass das irgendwas macht beim ausführen
also wenn ich jetzt sag sagen wir mal
warum zeigt er überhaupt ist mal blöd frau am zeigt er überhaupt die hilfe an
kann ich das gut command nicht direkt ausführen also wenn ich jetzt hier mal
was ich irgendwas printe dann macht also dass das wird schon ausgeführt danach
aber warum macht er standardmäßig überhaupt die hilfe vielleicht will ich
einfach nur einfach nur ausführen
bilden 12 faktor etwas zum teufel seine 12 faktor app
Shell completion.
Cobra CLI add completion.
Okay, das probiere ich mal aus.
Wie soll das jetzt funktionieren?
Add completion.
Da hat er auch nichts gemacht.
welche application ja okay
das funks aber nicht was hier in dem in dem example drin steht
kann das jetzt hier mal machen ja und jetzt wird es aber nicht funktionieren
completion called, nice, da weiss man ja voll bescheid.
Das ist falsch, das stimmt nicht was da steht.
Kann ich jetzt sagen hier completion bash?
ist das von sich die anleitung ist pp gar nicht das klappt so nicht
ich weiß ich irgendwie sagt mir cobra nicht zu
work with command
ich will kein sub command ich will das main cup alles liest sich auch schon so eklig
Ach, daher weiß der, dass es das Command überhaupt gibt.
Leute, manchmal muss man nach seinem Bauchgefühl gehen.
Irgendwie gefällt mir Cobra nicht.
Das wirkt unnötig kompliziert.
wir probieren jetzt Kong aus.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es euch geht.
Wie war euer erster Eindruck?
Also irgendwie fand ich das
zu umständlich.
Ich weiß nicht, ich kann es schwer beschreiben.
Hat mir
vom ersten Eindruck her nicht gefallen.
Schwer zu sagen, warum.
Ich kann es gar nicht so richtig festmachen.
Aber wirkte irgendwie umständlich.
Wir machen das jetzt mit Kong.
So, Kong.
Command Line Parser.
Gucken wir uns mal an, wie das hier funktioniert.
Also, Import Kong.
Wisst ihr, geht schon viel besser jetzt.
Installieren.
Dann muss man sowas hier machen.
Also, war CLI struck, was es für Kommandos gibt.
Siehst du, das finde ich schon mal viel schicker.
Wie das so.
Also, dann machen wir jetzt mal was.
Was hat der für Schmerzen?
Ach, unused import, stimmt.
Wir sind ja in Go.
Go nervt ja immer rum.
Also, war CLI LS.
Wir löschen das mal.
Hier, AM brauchen wir nicht.
Oder, nee, LS.
Warte mal.
Hier, AM.
nennen wir das jetzt einfach mal
Data Deer oder so.
Ich will gucken, wie man da die
Optionen richtig
anlegen kann. Schau mal.
Force Recursive, ja, das ist okay. Path.
Aber nicht.
Aber die zwei Sachen.
So.
Okay, und jetzt, wie geht's weiter?
Üh.
Das sieht ja eklig aus.
switch
command
what
okay das finde ich jetzt nicht so schön
warum
warum kann ich nicht
sagen hier irgendwie
exec oder so
ich weiß nicht
das sieht eklig aus
naja
wir machen mal das Beispiel
vielleicht wird es ja noch besser
zu simpel
ich weiß nicht
guck mal hier
woher weiß ich das da
nee
chat geschrieben eine stunde getestet ich weiß jetzt sicher dass ich mich für oben
cloud entscheide für alle apps die ich extra brauche zähle ich ein dediziertes system auf
meinem server ich dachte ich kann alle die nextcloud apps über die nextcloud handy app
nutzen aber wenn ich alles der eigenen app das wäre ach kann man nicht die ganzen nextcloud
apps auch über die handy app nutzen die die man im web interface hat dachte die handy app wäre
eigentlich auch nur so web interface rapper oder so das wird ein typisches ding next cloud ist eine
riesige baustelle seit jahren schon das stimmt nicht next cloud ist nicht eine ist nicht eine
baustelle next cloud sind 30 kleine baustellen wir haben mehr oder weniger fertig
guck mal jetzt ist das ding
woher weiß ich denn jetzt
also ok ok
lul so woher weiß ich denn überhaupt jetzt was ich hier rein schreiben muss ich würde
mal genau das so würde ich das jetzt mal vermuten mal gucken ob das funktioniert
ob ich jetzt überhaupt so was ausführen kann expected data dir liegt es an dem
was dahin geschrieben haben oder okay das scheint wirklich so zu funktionieren data
dir gleich lul weh ach so das ist ein command jetzt habe ich verstanden
also cobra habe ich gerade ausprobiert cobra fand ich super durch die brust ins auge das hat
mir das hat mir gleich am anfang hat mir das nicht gefallen cobra habe ich gerade ausprobiert die
hatten die brauchen eine eigene cli um commandos hinzuzufügen und sowas oder
brauchen nicht aber die anleitung hat die benutzt dass das war ganz eklig
was mir gefallen hat ist dass die wohl eine automatische shell completion dabei haben
Wie sieht das jetzt mal mit Kong aus?
Das finde ich hier zumindest, wie man die Sachen definiert, schon mal viel schicker als mit Codra.
So, wie sage ich dem denn jetzt?
Ich lese mal kurz, ab und zu muss man mal auch plötzlich die Anleitung ein bisschen angucken.
Manchmal. Help.
Stimmt, wie sieht eigentlich die
Biete sieht das eigentlich aus
Wenn ich hier minus hell
Ja, das sieht doch auch ganz
Brauchbar aus, oder?
Romant
Ja
Damit kann man auch
Leben, sieht doch eigentlich auch ganz brauchbar aus
Die Hilfeausgabe
Okay, das ist auch so Command basiert.
Ich fände es halt viel nicer, wenn ich einfach das Programm ausführen könnte, ohne irgendwie so einen Command anzugeben.
ja also ich würde halt gerne einfach ausführen können und da sagt er mir das geht aber nicht
weil mir weil wir einen command brauchen aber vielleicht kann man das ja irgendwie umgehen
Ja, wegen dem Default Case
Panic der
Aber dieses Expected Data
Dir und so, das kommt ja schon hiervon
Irgendwo
Also man muss
Wohl
Einen Command angeben
Mal schauen, immer mal die Hilfe
Ein bisschen durchgucken
Ja, das ist das, was wir gerade machen.
Attach a run method to a command.
Okay.
Ah.
Ach ja.
Ja, das ist schicker.
Das ist schicker.
Das gefällt mir viel besser schon mal.
ja das finde ich besser das probier jetzt mal aus
ist die Musik irgendwie gerade doppelt so laut geworden gefühlt
anscheinend
das probieren wir jetzt mal aus also jetzt mal so CLI gibt es nicht das muss
jetzt schreiben wir es halt groß
das hier brauchen wir nicht
ok
das ist doch schon viel schicker
ja das ist natürlich
no run method found
ok
wie
ah
man muss das so
man muss das jetzt auslagern
ok also man braucht quasi
Wobei, was?
Wie, Moment, jetzt bin ich, ich bin, bin grad
verwirrt, was?
Achso, hier gibst du dann
die einzelnen Sachen an,
die du vorher definiert hast.
Also quasi
das da,
das da
machen wir raus und sagen irgendwie
Type
DataDir,
was anderes, Type, was weiß ich,
ähm, Start, so.
Start Command.
Und dann?
Ah, okay, nee, dann muss ich das hier wahrscheinlich hier reinschreiben.
Oder?
Was?
Auch ein bisschen unübersichtlich.
Ja, genau, okay.
Also hier irgendwie Start, Start Command und das kommt bestimmt dahinter.
Okay, das sieht doch schon besser aus.
Dann expect Argument, ja okay. Guck mal was die Hilfe sagt.
Start.
No run method.
Ach und jetzt
muss man sowas hier machen.
Also, jo,
das geht eigentlich voll klar.
Das finde ich jetzt gar nicht mal so schlecht.
Warum eigentlich L?
Das hier brauchen wir nicht.
Ja!
Das finde ich eigentlich ganz schick so.
Das gefällt mir eigentlich besser als
vorher mit diesem Switch Case.
Döns.
Ja, das ist doch eigentlich ganz nett.
Also das gefällt mir schon mal viel besser,
als die Sachen mit Cobra anzulegen.
So, jetzt können wir...
Aber die große Preisfrage
ist... Ach, guck mal,
wenn man Command hinten dran macht,
dann schmeißt er das weg
und nimmt nur den Anfang.
Das ist gut. Das ist gut.
Weil ich hab eben schon gedacht, ich müsste Start Command
und so eingeben.
Aber das checkt ja wohl automatisch,
wenn commands dran steht dass er nur den ersten teil nehmen soll okay also jetzt
muss man mal schauen wie wir dort ein paar optionen hinten dran noch bekommen
also ich will ich will quasi
ein verzeichnis angeben können und den intervall angeben können wie geht das wie
macht man parameter
vor und die soll bevor apply das brauche ich alles nicht
ach du meinst weil das hier start heißt ich glaube du hast recht was du auf der arbeit
was mit go ja ab und zu zum beispiel für custom metriken per prometheus exportieren
das mit go ganz nice weil go hast du halt ziemlich kannst du ziemlich gut für containerisieren weil
halt self-contained binaries rauskommen nimmst du deine go und nimmst dein go binary packst das in
irgendein distroless image und da hast du dann container image was 11mb groß ist und halt alles
enthält was du brauchst also für custommetriken benutzt benutze ich das auf der arbeit ein
prometheus exporter der kommt als sidecar in den kubernetes pod mit rein und der wird dann von
prometheus gecrawled. Symbolestript weiß ich gar nicht, keine ahnung, glaube nicht dass ich symbole
gestript habe. Moment die go binaries sind zwar ein bisschen größer als irgendein minimalistisches
ist rast ding oder so aber die halten sich trotzdem in grenzen also lasst mal kurz gucken
wie groß das ding hier ist ob es an die mann war ich muss da war das nicht h doch 2,3 2,3 mb ist so
so ein simples...
Wir können mal
strippen.
Darf man
Go-Binary
strippen und die starten dann immer noch?
Anscheinend darf man das.
Nee, das ist ja das Gute an Go.
Du brauchst keine C-Library.
Guck, wenn du Go so baust...
Ja, doch.
Wenn du...
Ja.
Wenn du Go so baust...
Oder so, ja.
wenn du Go so baust, hast du keine
Abhängigkeiten zu
irgendwelchen C-Libraries und sonst was.
Du kannst das
Du kannst das quasi
auf jedes Linux
seit Kernel
frag mich nicht
oder so drauf kopieren und es geht einfach.
Das ist ja das Nice an GoBinarys.
Ja, das kann sein,
dass sie da irgendwas statisch gelinkt haben.
Aber ich...
Weiß ich jetzt nicht genau.
wie die das machen.
Wobei es eigentlich nicht statisch gelinkt sein kann.
Weil du kannst in Go,
aber das musst du zur Compile-Zeit machen.
Weil du kannst in Go schon
andere Libraries,
also c interop machen aber da muss er cgo enable wieder ja ok ach keine ahnung wie das funst so
ja ja das ist also go buy nur du hast recht go buy nur die size ist allgemein jetzt nicht das
kleinste aber es hält sich echt den grenzen ich meine zahl 5,2 mb das passt schon
Das hält sich echt in Grenzen.
Ich glaube, meine Anwendung da auf der Arbeit, die ich letztens gebaut habe,
die so Custom Metering exportiert, die ist 8 MB oder irgendwie sowas.
Also das geht voll klar.
Go hat sicherlich nicht die kleinsten Binaries,
aber Go ist halt super easy in der Handhabung.
also ziel habe ich schon benutzt dass das funs eigentlich ganz okay ist für
high performance sachen nicht geeignet weil es ziemlich ein overhead hat und
es war ich auch ein bisschen kompliziert aber ein großes problem was ich mit
sego sehe ist dass du dadurch quasi die diese sache eigentlich auf gibt die go
auf ausmacht dass du deine binaries einfach auf jedes x beliebige system kopieren kannst und sie
gehen dass man kann c oder assembly linken aha weil sobald du ziel enable gucken ob man das sieht
guck es ist der nämlich linkt sobald ich ziel enable und dementsprechend hat es auch
eine dependency gegen die oder weiß ich glaube die pendels ist das falsche wort hat es eine
mindestversion von der von gelb c die und zwar die von meinem system das heißt wenn ich das
jetzt auf ubuntu 20 04 kopiert läuft es nicht mehr es ist doof guckt das kann ich euch auch
zeigen wir probieren das jetzt mal aus nicht dass ich euch das jetzt erzähle und das stimmt
alles nicht so muss ja nicht sein wir starten jetzt einfach mal einen docker container
Nehmen wir mal ein Ubuntu
Wir machen das mal so, wir nehmen ein Ubuntu 20.04
Ich maunte mir mal hier
Warte mal, wie rum war das?
Von zu mounten, ne?
Also ich maunte mir jetzt mal hier kurz
Den Kram rein
So, nach slash blub
Wird das jetzt gemountet?
So, slash blub
wir machen das anders jetzt war mir erstmal mal dass man das der städte klied
dass das das statisch gelingt ja jetzt ein go binary liegen dann starte ich
jetzt mal um 20 04 gehen wir nach fleisch blub da liegt jetzt mein go
binary trainer um cli champ zack und das funktioniert okay ich wurde als als steht
Ich habe Printline LS drin, das steht in dem Programm. Also siehst du, Funst.
Das kannst du jetzt auf jedes x-beliebige Linux kopieren und das Go-Binary
funktioniert. Wir schreiben jetzt mal da was rein, dass man sich das auch ein bisschen besser, dass da nicht LS steht.
Hallo, cute Chat.
Jetzt machen wir das Gleiche nochmal.
CD, blubb.
CLI Champs. Start muss man machen. So, Funst, CD.
Wenn ich das gleiche jetzt nochmal mache, mit C-Go-Enable 1, dann sieht man hier jetzt schon, das ist dynamically linked.
Jetzt starten wir nochmal den gleichen Container, gehen nochmal nach Plup und sagen CLI-Champ und siehe da, geht nicht, weil GLibc-Version zu alt.
chili habe ich mir noch nicht angeguckt ich kenne die sachen so ein bisschen mit farbigen
terminal output und tabellen malen und so was ich weiß dass die projekte gibt aber ich habe
noch nicht so viel mitgemacht guck und jetzt geht's nicht das ist halt der unterschied zwischen
self content go binary was keine abhängigkeiten zu c libraries hat und welche dies haben und
und dementsprechend ist das immer gut sofern man es nicht braucht und meistens braucht man das nicht
cgo auf disable zu stellen weil dann hast du ein schönes selfcontained binary was einfach überall
drauf läuft ich kann euch das auch mal beweisen damit der prime nicht verfällt das ist sehr nett
von dir excellent wilder igel danke schön für den sub wir kompilieren das ganze jetzt nochmal mit cgo
disabled und jetzt machen wir was ganz altes.
Okay. Wir machen jetzt...
Was ist denn das älteste Ubuntu,
was es als Container gibt?
10.04?
12.04?
Okay, das gibt es tatsächlich.
12.04 Ubuntu.
So, wir haben hier einen Kernel.
Achso, wir haben einen Container.
Leute, ich kann euch
das nicht zeigen, weil
ist ja ein Container.
Das ist ja mein Host-Körner.
Das ist nicht so schön, wie wenn...
Schade, dass der VM-Champ nicht mehr geht, oder?
Dumm, dass der VM-Champ kaputt ist.
Sonst hätten wir ein schnelles VM gestartet.
Naja, aber zumindest, was man hier dran sieht,
ist zumindest die ganzen Libraries,
die in dem Container drin sind.
Das Ding läuft auch gegen ein ganz altes, uraltes Ubuntu.
Das einzige was so ein statisches Go-Binary braucht ist ein Linux-Kernel seit 2006, 38 glaube ich.
Das einzige was beim 4M-Champ btw. noch funktioniert ist das hier.
Der Rest tut nicht mehr.
Oh, das geht nicht.
aber auch wichtiges feature oder man könnte fast sagen das wichtigste feature
so sieht's aus deswegen ist go halt einfach der king wenn es darum geht anwendungen die gut sich
für containerisierung eignen oder die diese mit denen für containerisierung vielleicht noch nicht
unbedingt durch dadurch dass oder alles mit wandeln kannst eignet sich eigentlich fast
alles für containerisierung aber wenn du beide haben willst du einfach irgendwo hin kopieren
kannst und die laufen dafür ist go einfach das beste container sind obsolet seit wann
sind container obsolet oder meinst du jetzt für die coolen leute die mit sachen mit nix
basteln heutzutage also ich würde mal sagen dass alle allermeiste dürften
irgendwelche also von anwendungen die so benutzt werden die man tagtäglich benutzt
back end des back end dürfte wahrscheinlich in irgendeiner
containerisierten form in irgendeinem wahrscheinlich kuba jedes cluster laufen
also zumindest sehr viel davon weil was ist die alternative wenn ich
containerisierung der eigene vm sowie früher
irgendwelche jede anwendung bekommt einen eigenen unterordner
ja das ist mit go tatsächlich einfach mit go kannst du einfach die beiden
riesen kopieren das funktioniert aber trotzdem kannst du dir kannst du dir in
die quere kommen dann muss der irgendwo deine loks irgendwo hinschreiben bros
in den port an dem du listen und so was schon gucken dass sie sich nicht auf der
gleichen vor allem irgendwie die quere kommen
es kann dir beim containerisieren ziemlich egal sein
und spätestens wenn du irgendwas brauchst was bisschen skalieren kann von
wir müssen das ding einmal starten bis zu wir müssen das ding keine ahnung 20
mal starten dann führt eh nichts mehr dran vorbei das zu containerisieren zu
containern
also ich würde eigentlich so weit gehen und sagen mittlerweile ist es fast schon
standard dass anwendungen im container laufen also zumindest bei uns auf der
arbeit ist so dass jegliche neue entwicklung gibt es ja ist das so
standards policy für den default java stack den sie da einsetzen natürlich
was sonst dass die ordentlich containerisiert laufen muss und das
klappt doch ziemlich große cluster mittlerweile stehen mit weiß ich was der größte ist 40 notes
oder irgendwie sowas läuft dann alles mögliche drauf meine cluster sind bisschen kleiner also
ich habe zwei services die auch auf kuba netz laufen der eine hat drei notes und andere glaube
vier oder fünf notes der skaliert immer ein bisschen wild rum und keiner weiß so genau
warum man manchmal fünf noch manchmal nur vier wobei ich will ich vermute ich weiß woran es
liegt aber ich habe das noch nie weiter nachgeforscht ich vermute das liegt daran
dass dort container drin sind die eine affinity haben in welcher zone sie laufen sollen also du
kannst ein zumal zu erklären ja wenn man bei einem cloud anbieter ist die hat
meistens verschiedene zonen so zumindest ich erkläre ich erkläre es mal wie es
bei google ist ja so es gibt regionen und zonen bei google ich habe wieder ich
habe so lange nichts mehr mit escher gemacht habe wieder vergessen wie der
ganze krempel bei bei escher heißt aber das gibt es überall jeder cloud anbieter
hat so ein Konzept von Regionen und Zonen.
Region ist sowas wie beispielsweise
Europe West 3
oder US Central 1
oder sowas. Das ist eine
Region. Und eine
Region besteht aus Zonen.
Da gibt es dann sowas wie
Europe West 3
ABC.
So, und wenn du da jetzt ein Cluster laufen hast,
ein Kubernetes Cluster,
mit 4-5 Nodes, da kann es ja so sein, dass du 2 Nodes in US Central 1A hast und 1 Node in B und 1 Node in C.
Das macht er so ein bisschen random verteilt hat das.
So, und jetzt ist es aber so, manchmal willst du, dass explizit deine Pods in einer speziellen Zone laufen.
Jetzt müssen wir mal wieder hier den High IQ des Chats erfragen.
Habt ihr eine Idee, warum man beispielsweise möchte, dass eine Anwendung in einer bestimmten Zone läuft,
anstatt einfach zu sagen, Kubernetes, mach mal, wie du willst, hau hin, wo du lustig bist.
habt ihr die idee warum warum könnte ich wollen dass eine anwendung explizit in
u.s. central 1a läuft und nicht in b&c ich gebe zu dass es gar nicht so einfach
drauf zu kommen wenn ich darauf komme ist auch nicht schlimm
also ein beispiel peering das könnte eventuell aber das meine ich nicht
was ich meine ist zum beispiel wenn du anwendungen hast die persistente disks
brauchen persistente disks hängen immer an einer speziellen zone dran es gibt auch replizierte
disks die hängen aber einfach an zwei zonen dran das heißt wenn du eine persistente disk hast und
halten ssd in der cloud dann gehört die zu einer bestimmten zone und vielleicht gibt es diese disk
nur in us central 1a oder müssen halt deine ganzen workloads in us central 1a laufen damit ihr auf
die disk zugreifen können oder auf die disks zugreifen können diese brauche so und deswegen
glaube ich skaliert unser cluster manchmal ein bisschen wild rum weil wir haben da eine
anwendung drin die hat eine zone affinity die muss quasi dort laufen ich sage jetzt einfach
hier in u s central 1a weil dort die disks sind und manchmal hat er halt ein not da manchmal hat
er zwei notes da und umgedreht und deswegen skaliert ja manchmal ein bisschen hoch und
bisschen runter je nachdem wo grad was läuft manchmal kommt damit drei notes aus oder eben
manchmal komplett vier notes aus manchmal brauche fünf je nachdem wo grad platz ist und und die
definitiv für die disks passt das kommt öfters vor dass der cluster mal aus fünf notes besteht
es kommt auch öfters vor dass der kassel aus vier notes bestehen aber wir wollten eigentlich
eigentlich Go-CLI-Anwendungen
basteln.
So. Also.
Run.
Kunst.
Ich mag Podman nicht.
Ich kann dir aber gar nicht so 100%
sagen, warum.
Ich benutze einfach für
alle möglichen Sachen Docker
und das war's.
Theoretisch ist Podman
sagen sie ja zumindest, ein Drop-In-Replacement
zum größten Teil.
Boah.
Schniesen.
Aber ich mag Podman nicht.
Was bei Podman ganz cool war in der Vergangenheit,
war diese Geschichte mit rootless Containern
und sowas. Aber ganz ehrlich,
ist mir vollkommen egal,
wenn ich ein Container-Bild mache.
Ach du, okay,
Docker Desktop weiß ich nicht.
Docker Desktop habe ich noch nie verwendet.
Ich benutze immer das Docker CLI.
Das einzige, was ich damit mache,
ist eigentlich Container bauen
und Container tanken,
Container bauen, Container tanken,
Container pushen und mal testweise
einen Container starten. So, das war's.
Also ich habe jetzt da
keine lokalen Anwendungen oder so
großartig drin laufen bei mir auf der
Admin-Kiste.
Aber Container bauen,
Ich finde Docker eigentlich immer noch am angenehmsten.
Wahrscheinlich ist es keine Gewöhnungssache.
Wie dokumentiert ihr auf Arbeit bei euch die einzelnen Anforderungen von Anwendungen?
Also abseits von Tickets in Jira und Co.
Gar nicht.
Nee, das stimmt nicht.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Damit muss ich mich glücklicherweise nicht beschäftigen.
Ach so.
Ich sollte vielleicht mal weiterlesen, anstatt dass ich da schon mal irgendwas zu sage.
Achso, da geht es gar nicht drum. Moment.
Also abseits von Tickets in Jira und Co., die man braucht, um die Dinge im Sprint abzuarbeiten.
Ne, da habe ich doch richtig verstanden.
Um die Dinge im Sprint abzuarbeiten.
Also wirklich detaillierte Anforderungen meine ich, wo alle Einzelmerkmale und das Verhalten der Anwendungs...
Dafür haben wir Verantwortliche für die Anwendungen, die machen das.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie die das machen, wo die das machen.
Es gibt so eine Anwendungs-DB, so eine Services, Services, Services, wie heißt das Ding?
Services-Portal oder irgendwie sowas.
Vergessen, wie das Ding heißt.
Das sind alle Services, also Service gleich Anwendung, in der Regel.
Ein Service kann auch aus mehreren Anwendungen bestehen.
drinne und da kann man draufklicken und da sieht man dann so sachen wie wer ist
dafür zuständig was weiß ich für die anwendung für die administration für
release planung und so was aber
da ist dann bestimmt auch irgendeinen link drinne zu einer weiteren datenbank
oder sowas wohl wo so dinge drin stehen habe ich mir noch nie angeguckt es gibt
bei uns für die administrative seite sowas da muss einmal im jahr für jede
anwendung muss ein dokumentations pdf generiert werden und das ist absoluter
painstamp prozess warum pdf generiert werden muss liegt daran also meine
vermutung zumindest liegt daran die wollen für den fall der fälle gewappnet
sein wenn sie wirklich mal großen ausfall haben oder irgendwie der
hacker man am start ist und keine systeme mehr gehen da wollen sie quasi
dass du das sind das notebook aufmachen kannst mit einem pdf drauf und kann es
trotzdem die alles angucken was du brauchst um die anwendung wieder zum
laufen zu bringen ist ja von der idee her auch nicht verkehrt einmal im jahr
quasi so einen anwendungs overview pdf zu generieren
ob das in der Praxis funktionieren würde,
ich hab da so meine Zweifel.
Und wie aktuell
diese Dinger sind, hab ich auch
meine Zweifel. Nur weil die einmal im
Jahr generiert werden, heißt ja lange nicht,
dass der Inhalt auch aktuell ist.
Ich generiere auch öfter so
Anwendungs-PDFs.
Und ich geb zu, ich bin
jetzt vielleicht nicht unbedingt der
der Eifrigste beim Aktualisieren
der Inhalte.
Aber zum Glück sieht man, wenn man eine neue Seite anlegen muss, dann wird das immer so rot.
Es gibt irgendwie so ein Mustertemplate dafür, für diese Betriebsbücher, die es da so gibt.
Und dann gibt es so ein Mustertemplate für und wenn in diesem Mustertemplate oder in diesem Base-Template eine neue Seite dazugekommen ist
und du willst dann PDF einmal im Jahr generieren, dann sagt das, nein, das geht nicht, du darfst PDF nicht generieren, da fehlt noch eine Seite.
Dann musst du dir da irgendwas aus den Fingern saugen.
Wie lange bist du schon auf der neuen Arbeit?
Äh...
Zweieinhalb Jahre?
Also so neu ist die neue Arbeit gar nicht mehr.
Ich glaube zweieinhalb Jahre.
Ich glaube 2023
Chat, ich muss mal gucken, ich weiß es selbst
gar nicht mehr, aber ich habe ja zum Glück
Moment, warum denkt er, ich bin der Lost Aiming?
ETF
Google
Lass mal kurz gucken, ich habe ja zum Glück
Ich habe ja zum Glück ein Video
Was ist dein Jahresgeld?
Da kannst du dir auch ein Video bei mir auf dem Channel
dazu angucken und zwar
habe ich ein Video gemacht
Wo ist das Video?
So viel verdiene ich jetzt.
Ich glaube, das ist es.
Hoch.
Chat.
Ich habe zu viele Tabs.
Ich habe es kaputt gemacht.
Hallo Leute.
hier erzähle ich das glaube ich ja das ist das ist das so ich habe die neue arbeit die bin ich seit
morgen ist schluss letzter arbeitstag okay nur noch und zwar am ja also seit
seit erstem april 2023
ja du musst dir das video angucken weil da gehört ja ein bisschen was dazu
Das kann man nicht so einfach erklären, weil ich beispielsweise Teilzeit arbeite und ich mal mehr oder weniger Bereitschaft habe und da Bereitschaft, also Wochenendzuschlag und sowas kriege.
Du musst dir schon das Video angucken.
Aber das ist noch aktuell.
Es ist mittlerweile nur noch ein Ticken mehr geworden, kleines bisschen mehr, weil es eine automatische Gehaltserhöhung gab.
da habe ich nicht gesagt
der inflationsausgleich haben wir auch bekommen was es gab ist ich habe ich
habe einen nicht tarifvertrag ein außertarifvertrag jetzt habe ich
ein außertariflichen vertrag so meist das glaube ich korrekt aber wir haben halt auch viele die
werden nach tarif bezahlt und jetzt ist es ja so überlegt euch mal leute die außertariflich
bezahlt werden was ist leute die tariflich bezahlt werden wenn die leute die außertariflich bezahlt
werden quasi nie eine gehaltsanpassung kriegen außer wenn sie die permanent selbst nerven und
die tariflich bezahlt werden quasi alle 1 bis 2 Jahre eine Gehaltsanpassung
automatisch bekommen dadurch.
Bedeutet ja, irgendwann würden die Leute mit Tarifvertrag
deutlich mehr verdienen, als die Leute ohne,
also die außertariflich angestellt sind.
Weil die die dann irgendwann überholen würden.
Deswegen machen sie das bei uns so,
dass in der Regel die Erhöhung, die es für die Tarifverträge gibt,
auch die Leute, die außertariflich
einen außertariflichen
Vertrag haben, bekommen quasi
mehr oder weniger die gleiche Erhöhung.
Was ich sehr nice finde, weil
da muss ich einfach nichts machen
und kriege trotzdem mehr Geld.
Soll mir recht sein.
Finde ich eine gute Regelung.
Mani in Frankfurt.
Ja, Frankfurt
gerade Versicherungen
schrägstrich Banken.
Also jetzt bin ich bei der Versicherung.
Davor war ich bei einer Bank.
Und in der Finanzbranche,
da gibt es in Frankfurt
doch ganz gut Kohle.
Ich bin jetzt ein bisschen sidetracked von
GoCLI-Anwendung.
Eigentlich
wollten wir uns das hier angucken.
Aber wenn ihr Fragen habt, könnt ihr trotzdem
einfach los
schießen.
Ah ja, Inflationsangleich
gab es auch. Aber ich weiß
gar nicht, ob es letztes Jahr auch einen gab.
Ich glaube, ich weiß es gar nicht mehr.
Also einmal habe ich auf jeden Fall einen gekriegt.
Aber fragt mich jetzt nicht, wie viel.
Keine Ahnung.
So.
Also, dann gucken wir mal weiter.
Wie macht man denn jetzt hier in Kong
Environment Variablen zum Beispiel?
Ich muss mir mal die Hilfe.
Spielst du Battlefield 6? Nee.
Ich werde aber dann im November spätestens spielen, weil da muss ich Windows neu installieren und dann geht auch Secure Boot.
Ich kann gerade nicht. Ich kann gerade nicht mich auf Games großartig konzentrieren.
Es liegt nur zum Teil an Secure Boot, dass ich nicht spielen kann.
Ich habe ja immer noch so ein bisschen meine Probleme.
Ihr wisst ja Bescheid.
Und wer es nicht weiß, kann sich das alte Stream da aus...
Ich will es jetzt nicht jedes Mal erzählen.
wisst ihr eigentlich dass das heute quasi ein ärztlich verordneter stream ist das
eigentlich klar also nicht für euch für mich ist das ein ärztlich verordneter stream was
habt ihr für kubernetes plattformen in der arbeit open shift gk google kubernetes engine
so ist es ja früher loops gebäscht heute werde ich gebäscht wahrscheinlich wobei
ganz im ernst immer wenn ich wieder angefangen habe und mal ernsthaft ein
paar wochen gespielt habe habe ich die nubs wieder gebäscht
Nee, wie ich das meine ist, ich habe euch doch erzählt, ich mache gerade eine Therapie, so psychisch.
und
der Therapeut hat zu mir gesagt, Herr Max,
wenn Sie sich mal wieder zu viele Gedanken machen
über irgendwelche
Sachen, die so passieren oder passieren könnten,
dann setzen Sie sich doch einfach
an den Computer und machen den Livestream an.
Das hat er wirklich so gesagt.
Und da habe ich mir gedacht, okay,
dann mache ich heute einfach mal den Livestream an.
Base, ne?
Du meinst, es laufen so viele Noobs rum in Battlefield gerade?
C.
Gegen C habe ich nicht.
Zum Glück hast du nicht C++ gesagt.
Brutale Noobs.
Okay.
Vielleicht soll ich doch mal
Secure Boot einschalten und nachher Battlefield starten.
das müsste ich das nächste mal sagen ich glaube er kennt meinen channel nicht aber ich habe immer
erzählt dass ich dass ich youtube und twitch content mache wobei das ja mit youtube content
wenn ich mir so mein upload plan angucke auch schon ein bisschen bisschen er ist also wo sie
auf jeden fall nicht größer c ist ist diese eklige pointer syntax in sich so dieses ist das hier das
ist ein Pointer in SICK. So sieht der aus.
Lieber
C++. Moment, es gibt einen Clip,
dass ich lieber C++ benutze.
Das kann doch nicht sein.
Ich glaube, man fährt
trotzdem mit C++
in dem Fall besser.
Ich glaube... Moment.
Das ist wahrscheinlich ganz
hart aus dem Kontext gerissen.
Ich weiß nicht mehr,
um was es da ging. Aber das ist
auf jeden Fall hart aus dem Kontext gerissen.
Man ist bei den meisten Sachen nicht mit
C++ besser beraten.
Ich glaube, es ging da drum,
dass wenn man Microcontroller
programmieren will, irgendwie Rust vs.
C++, dass man mit
C++ da immer noch besser beraten ist.
Ich glaube, das war das vermutlich.
Natürlich so diese zwei Sekunden da rausgeschnitten.
Achso, wollten wir nicht eigentlich Go machen?
Wir sind richtig weit gekommen oder
Genau ich wollte hier noch meine hilfe reingucken wie man da jetzt zum beispiel environment variablen und so was machen kann bind option
Das arguments zu
was was moment jetzt verstehe ich nicht was wollen wir sagen meint author name
pinguin
ich verstehe überhaupt nicht was ich hier sehe
Ach so, das ist, wenn ich selbst...
Ach, wenn ich selbst so tun will, als würde da ein Argument übergeben, oder wie?
Was habt ihr da noch für...
Lips.
Man muss aber sagen, C++ ist von der Sprache her äußerst simpel.
Man muss aber sagen, C++ ist von der Sprache her...
Das ist auch wieder komplett aus dem Kontext gerissen, Alter.
C++ ist wahrscheinlich das komplizierteste, was es gibt.
flag. Ah ja, genau, das will ich haben.
Flag String. Das ist gut.
Also, mein Start Command
soll ein
Data Dear, das ist ein
String.
Pass to Data
Dear. Das ist vollkommen egal, wie das
heißt.
Und dann wollen wir noch ein
Intervall.
Das ist ein Int.
Kann ich sagen, ein Int 8.
E-Fresh-Intervall.
Wir machen es in
Seconds.
In 8-ter-Vall.
Fände ich gar nicht mal schlecht.
Liest sich gut.
Er ist auch so ist auch so keine ahnung was was da wieder der chat geklebt hatte
Ich werde nie den c++ tutorial machen weil ich mir nicht anmacht zu sagen ich hätte c++ verstanden
Aber da bin ich in guter gesellschaft ich glaube noch nicht mal dass c++ gremium versteht c++
Gibt es meinte es gibt wirklich irgendjemand der von sich behaupten kann er hat c++ verstanden
Weil c++ hat auch sachen in der sprache die eigentlich
also die nicht zu verstehen sind
was die musik ich bin verwirrt
achtung
ich habe zu viel zeug auf ich blicke in meinen tabs nicht mehr durch hier so viele
ich mache das jetzt mal ein bisschen lauter dass man es hört achtung ja ich habe zu viele
tabs das ist immer noch so hat sich nicht geändert oder wenn ihr euch das hier anguckt
ok also jetzt will ich jetzt ok data die er inter also wenn ich jetzt help eingebe minus
h dann sagt er mir auch schon mal st aha siehst du dass ich schon mal was was mir nicht gefällt
ich muss sagen start minus h dann sagt der data die string intervall in acht achter sagt sogar
was es ist da hinten.
Okay, das wird wahrscheinlich
die meisten...
Okay, das
müssen wir jetzt mal ausprobieren. Was passiert
denn jetzt, wenn ich jetzt
hier sage, minus minus
Intervall gleich
1. Das funzt schon mal.
Das ist klar. Aber was ist, wenn
ich sage, minus minus Intervall, den da?
Ah!
Expected and valid 8 bitint.
Das ist nicht
schlecht.
Das finde ich eigentlich ganz gut, dass er das gleich verifiziert, eine passende Fehlermeldung dazu hat.
Finde ich eigentlich ganz nice.
Wie kann ich denn jetzt von hier darauf zugreifen überhaupt?
Sagen wir mal hier, Log.
Print F.
Oder hier, keine Ahnung.
So.
Und jetzt.
Ah, so, Intervall.
So kann man da drauf zugreifen.
Ach guck mal, jetzt gibt er eine 1 aus und jetzt hier 12, gibt er 12 aus.
Okay, das ist auch...
Also ich muss sagen, Kong geht relativ easy von der Hand für Command Line Parsing.
Und jetzt ist die Frage, wie kriegt man Environment Variablen rein?
Commands and Subcommands.
Ne, ich will kein Subcommand haben.
Ich will einfach nur ein Main Command haben.
Mehr will ich gar nicht.
Aber das scheint nicht zu gehen.
Branching positional arguments, what the fuck?
Ne, so kompliziert will ich gar nicht machen.
Slices?
Brauch ich auch nicht, brauch ich auch nicht.
beste Data Structures.
Jetzt ist mir das zu high IQ.
Was bin ich hier sehend?
Ach so, für einen
Inum kann man hier sogar
die Werte, die erlaubt sind, angeben.
Das ist eigentlich ganz schick.
das ist ein gutes zitat custom name das brauche ich nicht supported field types
supported tags aha cmd arg nf das ist es doch das brauche mal wie sieht das jetzt so taktisch aus
einfach irgendwie dahinter specify nf variables to use for default value wir machen mal kurz hier
das Print ein bisschen schöner.
Ah, nicht wirklich.
Äh, Chatgear.
Print F Syntax
in Go. Das war doch sowas wie hier
keine Ahnung. Ah ja,
genau. Prozent.
Warum plus V?
Warum nicht Prozent V?
Warum muss da? Was ist denn
der unterschied zwischen prozent v und plus macht das in den unterschied
oder okay wir fragen chat gpt
difference between dem und los fall
Gut, Frage.
Aber es beinhaltet auch
Fieldnames von Printing Structs.
Ah.
Verstehe.
Ach so.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Wartet mal.
Wenn ich jetzt Plus davor mache.
Ach, das ist ja cool.
das ist ja nice das war mir nicht klar dass das geht
der print ist die feldnamen vom strakt das ist eigentlich ziemlich cool
das gefällt mir das hat was
es ist immer wieder was gelernt chat wusste ihr das dass man strakt vielen
field namen printen kann mit plus von v
wird es nicht der krasse go checker der chat blickt natürlich bestimmt wieder alles und wusste das sofort
aber für mich ist das für mich ist das neue
ok weiß so aber wir wollten eigentlich entfachen machen
so also ich wenn ich jetzt data die data die er über eine environment variable setzen will
das heißt dann schreiben wir hier rein die hier rein schreiben wir 11 und dann zum beispiel der
environment variable ja keine ahnung cli anders core data dir zum beispiel so noch ist data dir
lehrer und jetzt gucken wir mal hier export liegt leute passwort liegt post
passwort machen das mal hier vorne hin cli data dir gleich
lob kunst guckt er ließ die sachen aus die ließ die sachen ausnehmen
aus der Environment-Variable ein, wenn sie nicht
specified sind.
Wenn ich angebe,
dataDir gleich
D, dann überschreibt
das natürlich, ja.
Okay, das ist eigentlich ganz gut.
Das gefällt mir. Also ich muss sagen, Kong
geht easy von der Hand.
Wie macht man denn Default,
wie macht man denn Default Values?
Nee, Default gibt es nicht anscheinend.
Das wäre nice, wenn es ja in Cobra
musst du das ja irgendwie mit Viper machen und sowas.
Aber so weit bin ich gar nicht gekommen.
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Long Name for Overriding Field Name.
Permanent Help Text. Type.
Was?
Ne, Permanent Placeholder.
anstatt dass er den ok verstehe anstatt dass er hier anzeigt string und in acht könnte man
hier beispiel reinschreiben okay die ford value was die ford x default value die ford
1 ohne command make it the default ach so
Ach so.
Ah, das ist gut.
Das heißt, ich pappe...
Das Wotran hier.
Default with Arcs.
Und jetzt kann ich Start weglassen.
Ja.
Das einzig Blöde ist nur, dass er das immer noch in der Hilfe so schreibt, dass ich ein Command brauche.
Also bringt mir das nicht wirklich was.
Da kann man es auch weglassen.
Ich glaube, die Musik ist wieder abgekackt.
Dann lassen wir das weg mit Default.
aber das schon mal nicht verkehrt also soll jetzt die default value
So sagen wir mal Default Value, wenn nichts angegeben ist,
wenn nichts angegeben ist, dann ist das Default slash Data. Gibt es nicht oder
hier oder keine Ahnung. Punkt slash Data. Also probieren wir das nochmal aus.
genau nichts angegeben und sobald ich es per environment variable angebe ist es plopp das
ist das ist sehr nice okay was natürlich blöd ist ist wenn ich es leer machen aber gut das gefällt
mir echt gut kommen was haben wir denn sonst noch hier short name flag brauchen wir nicht alias
brauchen wir auch nicht. Required optional hidden will ich nicht. Ach wenn man so ein
Flag wie beispielsweise verbose, wo man nicht merken kann ob es verbose oder verbose ist,
kann man dann quasi No-Verbose machen davor, ohne dass man dann extra Flag hinzufügen muss.
Eigentlich auch ganz nice.
Kopieren.
Prefix für...
Gibt es auch Prefix für Env-Prefix?
Kann man das global machen?
dass ich sage
env-prefix ist
CLI
und dann kann ich das hier weglassen.
Ne.
Das geht so schon mal nicht.
Na gut, dann nicht.
Hast du eigentlich den Omega-Lull?
Ach, den Oracle.
Du hattest hier bei mir einen Zeilenumbruch
dahinter. Hast du eigentlich den
Omega-Lull?
Hast du eigentlich den Oracle-Hack mitbekommen?
Ich hab irgendein Video
letztens aufploppen sehen bei mir in der YouTube-History.
Aber
nicht
keine ahnung also ihr könnt mich ja mal wie nennt man das im business in der
büste sprache ihr könnt mich ja mal aufgleisen kennt ihr dieses blöde wort
auch bei uns wird das oftmals verwendet wenn jemand sagt er erklär mir doch mal
was sache ist könnt ihr mich mal aufgleisen das ist richtig grinsch
Aufgleisen.
Gleist mich mal auf, Leute.
Was ist denn mit dem Oracle-Hack?
Oracle-Hack.
Ne, das ist irgendwie...
Also, das ist schon alles ein bisschen länger her.
verbos
okay
oder verbus
verbos
würde man da jetzt auf deutsch sagen
okay, jetzt haben wir uns eigentlich
alles mal weit angeguckt, was Kong
so bietet, wie macht man denn jetzt Autocomplete
damit?
Irgendjemand meinte vorhin, Kong unterstützt
Autocompletion.
Zweck?
Dynamic Commands.
Ach, guck mal.
Der unterstützt sogar
JSON-Files.
Ja, das ist ja richtig nice,
dass das da alles eingebaut ist.
Guck mal, da kann man sogar
sagen, man will die Option haben,
entweder von der Command-Line, von der
Environment-Variable oder aus dem Config-File.
Ja, das ist schick.
Das gefällt mir
Concompletion Package
Oracle Zero Day Preach
Okay, schon ein paar
Ist eine Woche oder so her
Das wäre jetzt aber zu high IQ, ehrlich gesagt.
Was ist denn
Too Long Didn't Read?
Exploited by
Klopp?
Enterprise
Become Attack Vector Overnight.
Wirst du auch Shortform
supporten? Das ist eine gute Frage.
Das stand hier doch irgendwo.
Ja, ja, das wäre auf jeden Fall sinnvoll.
Guck mal, Short.
Kann man dann sagen.
Hier Intervall.
Sagen wir jetzt einfach mal Short.
Für Intervall ist I.
Und jetzt kann ich auch gleich sagen.
Hier minus I.
Hä.
Guck.
Funzt.
Achso.
Ja gut.
Schick.
Also ich muss sagen.
Cron gefällt mir.
Das ist schön.
Schön simpel.
und macht alles, was man so haben will.
Und jetzt gibt es noch was.
Kong Complete gibt es noch.
Kong Complete.
Na gut.
Was auch immer
ich mir hier gerade angucke, ehrlich gesagt.
Ist das
irgendwelches Hundespielzeug oder was?
GitHub.
Kong Completion.
Tab Completion
for
Kong CLI Apps.
das ganze sieben sterne aus heißt nicht dass es mit nix taugt
completion ist ein job in library der projekte completion for
sie als written with kong getting started so ein example wäre schon sehr nice
also code sample
Okay.
Kong Completion.
Lasst es sinken.
Nice, der Sinker.
Okay.
Create Kong App, but don't run
Arc Parsing yet.
Okay, dann müssen wir das
ein bisschen anders machen.
ok so ok und dann kommt komplettion register
kontext predict names weiß ich was da rein soll
Warum soll ich das erste Argument abschneiden?
Ich lasse es mal so wie es ist.
Das ist mir jetzt gerade ein bisschen zu hoch ehrlich gesagt.
Haben wir hier ein ordentliches Auto complete?
Pass.
Achso.
Ach, da gibt es gar keinen Run jetzt mehr?
Aha, ich hab da Mist gemacht
So
So ist richtig, glaube ich jetzt
Okay
Und jetzt muss ich erst nochmal Error checken
Kann das eigentlich Go automatisch generieren?
Kann Go nicht, kann oder kann Go Land nicht sowas?
Nee, ich muss jetzt gucken
If Error
Ungleich 0, dann will ich sagen
Der Log Fatal If Error
Gibt es ja nicht, ne
Kann man das irgendwie schöner machen, den Go?
Irgendwie kürzer? Knackiger?
Hoffentlich, ja.
Was will der jetzt hier eigentlich?
Da muss man...
Ja, das ist ein bisschen eklig.
Kann ich das denn einfach so da reinhauen?
das geht ja in go wieder nett ne?
oh boah, doch funzt. so. imported not used, ja ja bla bla bla bla. so register. so was muss ich
jetzt machen für autocompletion? predict names. was ist predict names? custom
Unprediktor.
Ne, das brauch ich doch überhaupt nicht.
Das kann man doch weglassen, oder?
So.
Und jetzt hab ich sowas wie Completion.
Unexpected Argument Completion.
Ne.
So funzt das schon mal nett.
Ach so, das muss ich noch hinzufügen.
Ach so.
Achso, achso, achso, okay, ich hab nix gesagt.
Also hier.
Completion, Con, Completion, Output, Shellcode for initializing, Tab.
Completion.
Das funzt.
Das ist ja cool.
So und jetzt sourcen wir das mal.
Wobei das ja nicht so ganz stimmt, was da steht.
Aus .slash CLI champed.
Äh.
Was mache ich falsch?
Unexpected Argument Completion.
Achso, ich hab's noch nicht gebildet.
Ich bin ja auch doof. Go, build.
Tatsächlich.
So, und jetzt kann ich sagen,
CLI Champ.
Guck mal, jetzt hab ich Shell Completion.
Aber,
der completet mir keine.
Doch.
Ja, das ist nicht schlecht, oder?
Das ist eigentlich ziemlich nice.
Das ist easy.
das gefällt mir gut
also das hat was doch das ist auch super simpel umzusetzen hier das ist nice also
das kann man echt benutzen ich glaube das werde ich mir für
zukünftige sie alle apps und bestehende sie alle apps mal merken das gefällt mir
also da das ist wirklich übersichtlich und mit dem completion package hast du
sogar auf dem box shell completion support
habe ich das eigentlich beim vm champ gemacht er hat auch shell completion
Ah, der completed alles, inklusive, inklusive, ähm, inklusive Options.
Na gut.
Oh ja, da verämmt Champ.
Chat, was meint ihr ist besser?
wenn der
also, guckt mal
wenn ich jetzt hier
was eintippe, soll der
Moment, ich
guckt mal, soll der
wenn ich jetzt hier Tab drücke
soll der jetzt dann automatisch die
die Optionen anzeigen
oder irgendwelche Files oder so
weil, es wäre
viel besser, wenn der Optionen anzeigen würde
aber da stand doch irgendwas drin
komplett completion shell default
komplett shell default false
wo muss ich das hinsetzen completion sub command
ok start
der
drückte nicht
Oh ne, also ich würde halt gerne, dass der direkt die ganzen Optionen hier, ohne dass ich ein Minus tippe, dass er mir die ganzen Optionen anzeigt, aber das geht anscheinend nicht.
Aber ist trotzdem ganz gut.
Complete, gibt's auch noch.
Outdated, Overrated, Cheapated.
Oh ne, die Musik ist wieder abgekackt
Was ist denn?
Guck mal, also wenn Google jetzt schon beim einfachen
Abspielen von Videos abkackt
Immer wieder
Dann ist doch echt
Ziemlich
Nur ein Arsch, oder?
Aber die Kombination gefällt mir
Das werde ich mir merken
das heißt das nächste mal machen wir einfach mit kong weiter oder oder wollen wir uns dann
noch mal cobra und wiper angucken aber eigentlich macht es hier alles was ich
haben will das macht files das macht environment variablen macht auto complete
eigentlich alles dabei.
Das kann man hier eigentlich noch als Optionen angeben.
Bei Register
Option.
Wirklich, oder?
Sollte der mir nicht eigentlich
Irgendwas sinnvolles Auto completen an der Stelle.
Wie funzt das jetzt?
Ach.
was kann ich hier angeben
ja
mit predictions leck overrides was auch immer das macht er händlers
das braucht man nicht ja nice exzellent
dann gucken wir uns das nächste mal an moment ich muss gerade mal kurz checken wie es wetter ist
ganz gut da gucken wir uns das nächste mal ein bisschen farbigen terminal output und so an da
gibt es doch hier hat doch vor und jemand schon geschrieben hier sowas hier in der richtung für
hat man sogar schon mal offen für farbigen terminal output
das ist aber auch wieder wissenschaft für sich
gibt es da examples für wie mache ich denn zum beispiel ein bisschen
side tracking jetzt aber ich mache einen spinner zum beispiel spinner so was hier
wie mache ich sowas in der shell boah boah ist aber ganz schön kompliziert ist aber
ganz schön viel für einen einfachen spinner
Spinner, New Program.
Okay, das gucken wir uns das nächste Mal an.
Das machen wir nicht heute.
Aber Kong gefällt mir für Command Line Parsing.
RCLI brauchen exzellente gestylte Terminal Ausgabe, wie soll das sonst funktionieren?
Und ganz wichtig, das allerwichtigste ist, du brauchst auch Emojis in der Ausgabe.
Was wäre irgendein Bild Command oder so, wenn da nicht irgendwie ein Kran drin wäre
oder ein Container oder sowas, Emojis.
Also das muss schon sein.
Stimmt, das muss aus sein.
Können wir das nächste Mal mit der Library dann machen, dass der KekW wieder ausgibt.
Und ohne Emoji Support geht nichts, stimmt, da gebe ich dir recht.
Das ist das Wichtigste.
Leute, die sprechen das ja nicht Emoji, sondern Emoji aus.
Ah ja Leute, war nice.
Ich geh jetzt nochmal ne Runde an die frische Luft.
Und wir hören uns. Bis dann. Macht's gut.